what's up you are the first one here or
the first one to say anything
and Henry answer what's up yeah
in recon so you're the first one to say
something Congrats congratulations
I absolutely loved it it was a great
movie um definitely funnier than the
first one like I will say that it's
definitely funny - the first one by the
way for those of you guys who were
trolling make sure you super chat I will
see your troll comments easier so um
anyway uh yeah I absolutely loved it
like I thought it was a great movie um I
mean in terms of like which one's better
I said the first one is probably better
overall in terms of just like plot but
as far as the whole like comedic aspect
this was definitely a lot funnier so um
it's pretty it's pretty enjoyable so
yeah almost 1 million subs 15,000 subs
and we cross a million so I'm pretty
excited hopefully the end of June
sometime in June hopefully that happens
maybe even the end of May to be honest
so uh I'm kind of excited for it the I
think it's going to be pretty like I
think it's pretty darn good it's pretty
enjoyable so let me show you some men
how was the soundtrack the soundtrack
was great it was really really enjoyable
there were some really catchy tunes
again I kind of feel like the first
soundtrack was pretty solid but um it
was pretty interesting so um let's see
who are the golden aliens they're just
an alien group that exists out there
they're there
significant so I'll get the soundtrack
was planned not at all like the
soundtrack was was pretty enjoyable so
um am I gonna do how to kill Vandal
Savage yeah at some point so um out of
ten if I had to give the first movie a
nine out of 10 I would give this one
like a strong eight like that I would
probably do there was it was really fun
so um I definitely got a kick out of it
so uh it's it's yeah you know it's it's
kind of cool so um let's see uh just
leaving IMAX now awesome movie yeah I
think Ronon was a better villain
definitely oh great Nate Bolton thanks a
lot for a dollar I appreciate it so um
yeah I really enjoyed I really enjoyed
it I really dug it a lot so uh uh do
more verses videos my favorite character
in the movie was actually Drax to be
honest I thought it was gonna be a baby
group and maybe it was really enjoyable
baby group was really really fun
but the Drax the destroyer was
definitely my favorite lucky lucky fifth
to off topic do you think Jane as Thor
was an attempt to be more PC make the
feminists happy I don't care about the
politics of why Jane Foster is for all I
know is that Jane Foster Thor is
probably some of the best Thor
storytelling there's ever been so yeah
Drax Drax stole the show will I do a
live spoiler chat yeah probably at some
point uh Erik
big day dig read I've really I'm
probably gonna screw up your name I'm
sorry been living vicariously through
your videos for a while now enjoy
some else talking about stuff I haven't
haven't read you oh that you have read
or have it well I appreciate it um
anything infinity war-related
I'm saving the spoilers for later seven
no spoilers for another time so um let's
see Amelio vanilla every time you
livestream I lose other Fox
I'm sorry I'm sorry dude I appreciated
that man Jackson nebula were pretty cool
yeah nebula had some great development
in this movie which I'm really really
glad to see um you know I'm really glad
to see that like she had some great
development so that was really cool
what's my pain of how the movie was
adapted from the comic book well here's
the thing the guardians of the galaxy as
you know them which is to say the
guardians of the galaxy in the movie
that was really that was the first time
we ever saw that team make up the comics
were adjusted to reflect that team and
so because of that I guess you know
really I enjoyed that chemistry to be
honest
wow great Nate Bolton thank you again I
enjoy that I enjoy that whole thing
yo Rob show them your muscles you know
you know I have them I do have them
they're just kind of hidden a little bit
I think other people trying to troll in
the in the chat again if you guys are
trying to troll make sure you super chat
because then I'll see them like I'll see
your troll comments I hope you are not
but if you use super chat that oh then
I'll see them so um Sammy Sammy smalls
love your work Rob I appreciate it Sammy
smokeless um can't wait to see the end
of the recap storyline oh yeah that's
going to be fun you guys are getting
robbed four rings by the way so Elijah
Taylor will you be covering the flash
blitz story I don't know what that is I
don't know where the flash blitz story
is Malik Gatson thank you I appreciate
it for ten bucks that's awesome
um yeah raava's lit I try to be
I tried what do you think of taser face
do the taser face moments were amazing
like like these are the coordinates to
yondu ship when you find him tell him
this comes from taser face and then she
just starts laughing at him I was
hilarious everybody was just laughing at
his name um men let's see uh your video
lag anything infinity war related again
I'm I'm not telling either way giving
spoilers for a different time so we I
have to answer that guy's a guy donated
I mean I can't ignore the I can't ignore
a message of somebody who donated money
and super chat like that that's just a
big move um but uh but yeah taser fans
you love my channel I appreciate it
what's my favorite what do I think the
best Marvel movie is so far it's gonna
seem a little dated to say this but I
still think the best Marvel movie to
date is Captain America the Winter
Soldier I think it's just I think it's
the the best storytelling I think it's
the most in-depth I think it is it's
probably the best you know in terms of
character development and all that kind
of good stuff it was pretty amazing
so the unwritten rules of the Internet
are unit rules of the universe yeah um
let's see uh
thoughts on inhuman suits sorry if I
asked this many times uh I don't know
about the inhuman suits and what we mean
you still haven't seen Wonder soldier
wow you really got to check it out
um but yeah the movie you know in terms
of its progression of the movie it made
sense Wow Andrew Pearson thank you for
ten dollars I appreciate it um the the
movie made sense for what it was it was
it was really really enjoyable it was
really stellar um I will definitely say
this uh them without without spoiling
anything the movie really feels like
like Doctor Strange it feels a lot like
Doctor Strange
Staley's not the one above all Oh in
comics yeah he's one above all in comics
um I mean I don't know why he would be
the one above all in the movies and yeah
like but um let's see uh let's see um
we'll get back to that later
oh man um anyway so so yeah without well
spoiling anything it felt a lot like
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange was
universe building and so this felt kind
of a lot like that like it was a fun
movie but it looked like it seemed like
Marvel was kind of killing time until
infinity war comes out so that was going
to be that was kind of a cool thing um
let's see uh are you sure was a dying
piece man she was hot but she's pretty
good-looking I will definitely give her
that like she's she was pretty hot like
you know thanks for all the hard work
Rob favorite Robin from TL thank you
favorite Robin is definitely Dick
Grayson just because of the legacy that
he created everything that he set up all
the stuff that he that he set in motion
um I kind of feel like he was the one
that made all that you know possible Wow
Norris uh sarong um Rob for Emperor
spartak CL may I buy a Rob for ring well
they haven't been made yet and I'm
trying to find a way to make them
affordable so that you guys can all buy
them but as soon as that happens I will
let you guys know um please do and
explained on my favorite Marvel
characters Schumer breath but I mean if
there's not much to do with him like
it's a storyline and that's really it I
guess I would just do this storyline you
know where he killed the watchman Colin
and in the comics but that would really
be about it
so um candles similar to I guess I
really I'm sorry if I mispronounced that
will I ever do a redeemable from Mark
Waid it's so good I've never read I have
no idea if it's good or no I have to
read it first to know if I wanted to do
it
I've never wind will Rob cameo in the
MCU movies let me tell you something man
if they offer me the ability to cameo in
the movies I would freak like okay
here's here's my idea of a cameo in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe alright give
me just like it didn't even have to be
lengthy like I'm just kind of chilling
there you know and it's like like some
events are unfolding or something like
that and there's a battle on earth or
someone those lines and like I'm just
sitting there watching the events unfold
I'm just vaping and it just kind of just
kind of pans over to me and it's just
like that's crazy and then that's it
like it no that's not you know or
something along those lines like that
would be my idea of a cameo but did baby
Groot steal the movie baby Groot had
some great roles in the movie but I felt
like Drax the destroyer ran away with
the film
I felt like JAXA destroyer was the one
that they kind of ran away with at all
he was definitely stellar so um let's
see yeah I read the new Walking Dead and
that's gonna be hard to explain no ma'am
you know I don't think of Roxas was
going to show them um see him I don't
see any reason why I would so ego was
kind of cool
again we're not really doing spoiler so
ego was okay I mean he's your user
traditional Marvel villain I'll leave it
at that he's like every mortal villain
ever so um did they do mantas justice Oh
they grabbed yeah um and do it how to
kill MODOK sure I guess um let me I
don't see reason not to heal bit later
on down the line but yeah I want to see
a reason not to kill him
we'll kill all kinds of people they did
her justice yes
mandus in terms of how she functioned in
relation to the guardians of the galaxy
in the comics when she was like you know
an empathic counselor and the comic
books sure
no but she was okay though um but yeah
so you mean an alive yeah YouTube is me
okay guys this this was not gonna be
super long word that worth about the
15-minute mark so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna start getting into
spoilers watch these numbers that are
gonna these numbers are going to drop
off so we're going to start getting into
spoilers so I'm giving you guys warning
giving us for your warning
and so the people who are starting to
join this are going to are going to
start getting into it so uh yeah
spoiler alert um let's see yondu
eternity man like like eternity i guess
is going to be kind of a struggle for
the folks who are gonna be like showing
up in the middle of this alright um yeah
so anyway that gum is really delicious
if I'm gonna chew it a little more after
I get done here um okay so if you guys
want to you super chat I'll answer your
questions you know as best I can I mean
I'll see them in all you know he's had a
better chance of seeing them you know
with that but I'm all answer you're all
spoiler questions as best I can
I don't know if I can change the title
can I change the title I don't know if I
can I can not Oh home what is this
glamour oh I can change the way it looks
beam that's Wow
dance party oh that's cool that's
amazing okay um all right uh yeah that's
that's pretty stellar like I can restart
the session with soiler you know we
should probably do that restart it with
spoilers um yeah I guess we can we can
go ahead and just do another livestream
session with spoilers because what I
don't want to do is I don't want to I
don't know people to join up and kind of
be left hanging you know and then
suddenly just be like bombarded with
spoilers okay so we're going to we're
going to finish this and then we're
going to go live again with spoilers so
that way you guys like we'll have the
whole the whole spoiler thing so I guess
we'll have to live streams I don't I
don't know though if I want to do two
live streams in one day because one of
having like three videos they go live in
a day I don't know um well so we'll sort
it out we'll get it figured out I have
no idea but um anyway so let's see all
right I'll be back here in a little here
in a second I guess yeah anyway see you
guys here in a second